[Music]
q4 of this year is going to be insane
shocktober when you hold up for when
you're playing football fourth quarter
and fourth quarter in the fourth quarter
fourth quarter
yeah they had us the first half i'm not
gonna lie fourth quarter baby they had
us the whole game but it's all about the
fourth quarter fourth quarter fourth
quarter
this is your time
their time
is done
the chairman of the federal reserve
explicitly saying no intention to ban
bitcoin obviously bitcoin is going wild
on the internet el salvador has started
to mine bitcoin using energy from
volcano the apex predator of the
financial markets is ready to roll you
play to win the game
hello you play to win the game going to
the fourth quarter of the football game
but they are who we thought they were
and we let them off the hook we can
fight our way back
into the light
we can climb out of hell we will not go
quietly into the night and remember what
got you here focus on the fundamentals
we've gone over time and time again we
can't be consumed by our petty
differences anymore
we will be united in our common interest
we have won every single game we have
played until now
so this team
is perfect
we'll give us a little four figures in
the air for the fourth
how we quarter finish it how are we
gonna close it out fourth quarter
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best because we said so
i'm here with my brothers the show that
we wish that we had when we were
learning about business investing in
finance
joe and john are here how do you know
their names are joe and john real simple
the names are on the back of the chairs
just hold them up just put them up let's
go you already know let's go fourth
quarter quarter we told you guys we
called it we told you bitcoin was going
to absolutely rip the supply squeeze is
underway that's why you're here this
morning bitcoin absolutely taking off
crossing over 54 000
a couple of weeks ago bitcoin was down
around thirty thousand dollars there was
people crying they were screaming and
yelling like little babies saying that
bitcoin's gonna go to 20k it's at 54 000
just like we said the on-chain metrics
do not lie during that drop in price all
we saw were the whales the strong hands
and your boys up here were just buying
as much as we possibly could because
that is what happens when you have a
fixed supply asset and demand increases
now before we get to all the fun today
remember we've got natalie brunell
coming on and also peter smith
blockchain.com we got a ton of content
for you when we go through today's show
we are going to do our absolute best to
educate you a couple laughs and jokes
and of course you already know that
we're going to give away money that is
what we do here we give away money so
that you can get to a life of financial
security
when we get to 500 likes we're at 250
likes on the count of three i want
everyone just to like it right let's not
get out of the let's not just right out
of the gate let's go we're gonna give
away money to start the show get a
little energy in here on a wednesday on
the count of three one two three smash
the like button when we hit 500 likes
we'll give away 250 dollars of bitcoin
live on the show to somebody who's
watching right now
oh john we're coming hot today i'm gonna
do it multiple times so let's just get
started with little bang uh don't forget
that sofi is the sponsor if we're gonna
have the best show we need the best
partner sofi.com
if you want to go and get free bitcoin
you go to sofi.com buy ten dollars worth
of bitcoin they'll give you ten dollars
for free bam five hundred already hit
five hundred dollars
out the door
listen might be worth more at the end of
the show i will i will go broke as long
as you all keep hitting that damn like
button all right what are we going to do
joe to pick the winner right in the game
three minutes i want you to uh to
comment in the chat what price you
bought bitcoin at at the f for the first
time what was the initial purchase price
you bought bitcoin at all right let's
see real quick in the chat comment
are you ready to pick somebody yeah all
right we're giving out don't lie all
right no one likes any people people
that are lying just tell us the truth
let's go 30 000. oh chat's blowing up
all right what do you got joe let's go
pick somebody quick well hang on hang on
let's let some people answer here no we
i don't got time let's go we got things
to do make sure you keep smashing the
like button too when we get to a
thousand likes we'll give out another
250 dollars
by the way the uh the speed at which joe
is making a decision we'll be giving off
that second 250 before joe picks
somebody all right all right i'm gonna
pick jamal abdali
jamal
how do you spell it
jim a j a m e l
all right a b you win
he bought it at 54 000. so my boy is
breaking even now let's get it
what all right so what i just said is
jamal what we need you to do jamal
winner winner winner winner you make 250
of bitcoin right now
uh in the chat leave us your twitter
account and then john will be in charge
of coming finding you tracking you down
and getting what's up jamal what's up
all right make sure you keep smashing
the like button when we cross over a
thousand likes we'll give out another
250 worth of bitcoin yesterday the sec
chairman gary ginsler was asked whether
he or the sec had plans to ban bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies and as you would
expect gary ginsler said no now this is
really important because last week we
saw the federal reserve chairman jerome
powell asked the same exact question do
you have plans to ban bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies the answer was no so we
now have the federal reserve chairman
saying no they do not plan to ban
bitcoin we also now have the sec
chairman saying that they will not ban
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies either
this is
two com two different points here one
they don't have the power to ban it the
sec has no right to oversee or ban
assets that are not considered
securities also the federal reserve is
not in the business of banning assets or
banning ownership of these types of
financial products
congress however does have that ability
so congress could
theoretically vote to actually ban
ownership of bitcoin in america now i
highly doubt that is going to happen we
have multiple congress people who
actually own bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
they understand that this is good for
their constituents there's tens of
millions of americans that own these
assets there has been hundreds of
thousands of jobs either directly or
indirectly created in this industry
there's trillions of economic value that
has been created by the industry and so
if you were to
come together and try to be adversarial
towards these assets it would likely
lead to a massive backlash from the
people it's very hard for politicians to
go against the will of the people and
the people want bitcoin and
cryptocurrency so it's great to see the
sec chairman saying this now when you
get regulatory clarity it's not full
clarity but it's a step in the right
direction when you get that all of a
sudden it gives the green light wall
street institutions individuals large
family offices everywhere across the
board people see something bullish like
that what do they do they go and they
buy a little more so it's not surprising
this morning that we saw bitcoin explode
upwards over 54 000
when we look at the charts we can see
bitcoin up over seven percent this
morning every other asset basically
doesn't matter they barely move compared
to bitcoin there is no volatility in
these other assets you've got boomers on
wall street who are celebrating a 0.96
move in the stock market today nobody
cares if you can't move with true
volatility no one who is young is going
to pay attention whether you like it or
not if we then go and we look at the
bitcoin stats themselves we can see that
bitcoin has officially regained the
status of being a trillion dollar asset
that means that the bitcoin network
which was created and launched january
3rd 2009 has now grown to 1 trillion in
market cap for only 12 years of
existence that is absolutely incredible
almost 90 percent of the bitcoin is in
circulation and then again remember what
i told you last week
20 billion dollars of on-chain
settlement volume has only happened a
handful of times about 78 different
times yesterday in the last 24 hours
21.6 billion dollars of settlement
volume occurred on chain not on the
exchanges actually on chain one of the
biggest days one of the top 10 days ever
for bitcoin settlement on chain people
are using this as a medium of exchange
regardless of what the mainstream media
or anybody else says the real exchange
volume over 10 billion dollars huge huge
numbers and then yesterday miners in the
last 24 hours made almost 50 million
dollars from that bitcoin block reward
not including transaction fees the
global revenue over the last 24 hours
four bitcoin miners was close to 50
million dollars the economic incentive
of this system is taking over and we are
watching an absolute fomo you've never
seen fomo like q4 bitcoin bull run fomo
and we are just entering it today if we
go ahead and we look at the actual asset
compared to the s p 500 in gold you can
see that bitcoin is up 408
over the last year these are video game
numbers if you go all the way back to
march of 2020 we kept telling you that
this was going to happen you can't print
trillions of dollars scare investors
into believing inflation is coming and
have them run for inflation hedge assets
and they happen to pile into an asset
that has a fixed supply of course it is
going to increase in value significantly
so 400 plus percent increase in the last
one year gold down 7
gold has failed as an inflation hedge
asset there is not a young person who is
trying to buy gold they are dumping gold
and they are buying bitcoin or other
assets and then you have the s p 500 up
28 over the last year if you go all the
way down to the 10 year yes
bang bang over 1 million percent
increase in the bitcoin price over the
last 10 years literally it's like asking
a second grader how much did it go up
and they're like 1 million percent yes
it is insane now if we go ahead and we
look at bitcoin gold s p 500 nasdaq and
the treasuries we can see them side by
side the roi of bitcoin of course check
mark it's beating everything but the
compound annual growth rate is now 158
over the last 10 years every year 158
compounded for a decade is unheard of
absolutely insane and so no matter what
statistic you look at whether it is how
many people are on the network how many
nodes are on the network how much mining
hash rate is on the network what is the
actual activity of those that are buying
or selling on the network everything is
bullish it looks like a big green light
for q4 bull run to commence this is the
second leg of the bull market we've had
this happen time and time again in bull
markets and so
the history is not a predictor of the
future
but damned is it rhyming now of course
this doesn't go unnoticed by people on
the internet and i just had to call out
the fact that jack dorsey the leader of
twitter and the leader of square he hit
us with a one t tweet today
well i don't know what jack was talking
about but it's probably not a
coincidence that when it hits a trillion
he then tweeted one t
and so no matter who you are everyone
really respects jack he's not seen as
some bitcoin ludite on the internet but
they are all watching it is so strong of
an economic incentive to participate and
as it goes up you take the social
consensus of i have to tweet about it
then if we look at charlie
lowe have we ever decided how to say his
name charlie bolillo who is fantastic on
twitter he has bitcoin rises to the
highest level since may it's up 88
from the low in june if you were buying
bitcoin in june you're up 88
absolutely stunning to see in a three or
four month period then if we continue on
the young wizard will clemente yesterday
hitting us with the long-term holder
supply shock has reached all-time highs
if you remember that green
bar across the top there every time that
we have entered into that long-term
holder supply reaching that green bar
what we have seen is a very very rapid
price appreciation afterwards again
history is not a predictor of the future
but the on-chain metric of long-term
holder supply is suggesting that you
should buckle up now if we then go and
we look well what are the miners doing
after a few weeks of selling
will points out that the miners have
actually started to accumulate again and
so when we look at this minor buying
you can see that price usually
appreciates following the start of minor
accumulation and so every single
statistic that we are looking at is
showing that there is bullish tailwinds
to this asset but my favorite chart my
favorite metric that anyone has pointed
out dylan leclair coming off the top
rope 360 windmill dunking saying never
in the history of bitcoin network has
this large a percentage of the
circulating supply been held for over
three months
85
of all bitcoin in circulation has not
moved in 90 days
that is insane the supply squeeze is
definitely underway dylan and so when
you start to look at the fact that 85 of
bitcoin has not moved in 90 days
regardless of price appreciation any
sort of volatility and then on top of
that
the chinese ban
two transactions occurred during that
time period as well it didn't shake
anyone out bitcoin holders are here to
stay and so if demand increases going in
to q4 i expect price to appreciate very
very rapidly
what do we think
about waking up and just seeing bitcoin
jumping seven eight percent and that
being thousands of dollars now it's wild
i love i mean i love it right we we've
talked about this all the time we're
obviously all uh us three are
financially incentivized for this thing
to go up so we're very clear about that
but i think when you look at the math
and we talk about this we talked about
yesterday we talked about it all the
time is it's very simple uh especially
how a lot of the on-chain metrics look
right now right so 21 million bitcoin
will ever be in existence 90 percent of
that is already existing and currently
circulating in supply 80 of the
currently existing bitcoin is held 85
over three months and 80 is being held a
record of people who are not willing to
sell it right long-term holders that are
notorious for just holding on to the
bitcoin not willing to sell it so when
you only have 20 of the available market
in circulation for people to buy and all
this demand is seemingly coming in right
we think that the etf is going to be
approved within the next three to six
months uh institutions are coming and
allocating capital to the space
companies are putting on their balance
sheet all these uh retail investors are
getting interested the network gets
stronger every single day you quickly
see how the supply shot comes into play
and the price appreciates rapidly right
so this is just the start of my opinion
i think over the next three months all
the conversations that we've had uh
between ourselves obviously will comes
on the show all the time and shows us
the metrics on chain but when you look
over the next three four five six months
you can quickly see how when that supply
is at such a low level in the market and
all these institutions come in all this
capital comes into the space the price
is going to appreciate pretty rapidly i
think john hit us with the math man what
do you got are you not entertained
come on we've been saying this is going
to happen for a while now shocktober
october whatever you whatever anyone
calls it it's absolutely insane
appreciation i like how some people use
it as a store value some people use it
as a medium exchange and we've seen that
in the numbers for a long time the
long-term hurdle holders continue to
hold bitcoin and it doesn't look like
they're gonna let it go anytime soon
i'm not selling my bitcoin i know you're
not selling yours uh so get it while you
can why it's uh why it's still cheap
they ain't coming to get mine
not getting any of ours all right we
just hit 1k likes we're giving out
another 250 worth of bitcoin right now
what i need is on the count of three
everyone hit the like button and we're
gonna give out 250 of bitcoin right now
in the chat what i want you to leave uh
a comment for is tell us
what is your favorite part about bitcoin
right now in the chat what's your
favorite part about bitcoin we're gonna
pick one person you're gonna get 250
worth of bitcoin right now live that's
it that's what the best business show
does is you come here all you have to do
is like the video we give out free
bitcoin to you for watching learning and
when you like the video more people on
youtube will find it
ready i'm going to just pick one person
randomly
jazzyj123
you're the winner you know why jazzy j
wins because that looks like an aol
screen name and i just feel like they
need to uh need to win you win
post
your twitter handle
and we will go ahead and we'll dm you so
jazzy j
is the winner john's gonna make sure
that you
end up on a uh
on a twitter thread with him and we will
get you 250 worth of bitcoin when we hit
1.5 k i'll give out another 250. today
i'm feeling generous bitcoins up this is
going to be a good day when we hit 1.5 k
likes we'll go ahead and we will give
out another 250. 2 000 likes we're going
to give out another 250. is that what
we're going to do today yeah we're going
to do a 2000.
so we're going to do that 1.52 at 2.5
we're going to do it let's see how far
we can get i don't know we'll see will
you split it with me sure
i ain't scared these guys don't make me
go broke up here just keep smashing that
like button we'll make sure we keep
handing you guys bitcoin all right u.s
banks are not going to get left behind
we just talked about how retail
investors are buying whales have been
buying they are holding 85 of bitcoin
has not been moved in the last 90 days
but the u.s banks are not going to let
this happen without them anyone on wall
street knows that if someone's going to
get rich wall street's going to make
sure they have their hand in the cookie
jar and so u.s bank is now announcing
that they have a cryptocurrency custody
service that will be available to fund
managers the offering will help those
investment managers store private keys
for bitcoin and a bunch of other assets
they're doing this with assistance from
new york dig ny dig nydig however you
want to pronounce it it's a major
bitcoin investment firm and the u.s bank
is one of the first institutions to have
a live custody product available the
regulation will be all checking the
boxes anti-money laundering kyc etc but
when we start to think about the fact
that these individuals at the bank see
such a big opportunity that they not
only want to give people exposure to buy
the assets but they also are going to
provide custody service remember when
institutions come into the market they
can do one of three things they can
either buy the assets directly they can
go ahead and they can put capital into a
fund that gives them indirect exposure
they can buy gbtc or bitw et cetera or
invest in one of the private funds but
then the third thing they can do is they
can build products and services in the
industry to drive cash flow that's what
u.s bank is doing here they are deciding
that they are going to go ahead and they
are going to drive revenue by providing
services and infrastructure and custody
to this industry we've got two quotes
the first is from gunjan
the vice chair of the u.s bank's wealth
management investment services division
and it says our clients are getting very
serious about the potential of
cryptocurrency as a diversified asset
class i don't believe there's a single
asset manager that isn't thinking about
it right now again this is not somebody
with laser eyes on twitter yelling and
screaming about bitcoin all day this is
the vice chair of the u.s bank's wealth
management and investment services
division saying our clients are getting
very serious i don't believe there's a
single asset manager that isn't thinking
about it right now well boys and girls
ladies and gentlemen remember that when
they start thinking about it the thing
they do next is they start buying it and
if they're buying it that means demand
increases and if demand increases and 85
of bitcoin hasn't been moved of course
the u.s dollar price has to appreciate
to accommodate everyone that is supply
and demand if you don't believe in
supply and demand you need to go back to
economics 101. now we have a second
quote from her which says quote what we
are hearing across the board is that
while every currency might not survive
there may not be room for thousands of
coins there's something about the
potential of this asset class and the
underlying technology that would be
prudent for us to stand up support for
it and so what you're seeing is that
she's actually talking about
while every currency might not survive
there may not be room for thousands of
coins there's something about the
potential of the overall asset class and
so do not be surprised that when these
institutions come in they're going to do
their absolute best not to take a
position on individual coins we like
this one we don't like this one instead
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
provide infrastructure so that they can
allow for people to come in use whatever
assets they want they don't care which
coins win which coins don't all they
want is more people joining into this
industry and using their products and so
it is encouraging to see them
participating but i tend to think that
most of these organizations are not
going to go as far as to have a
principled viewed or any sort of sandbox
that they draw around what assets are
actually going to survive and which ones
aren't that's okay it doesn't mean
necessarily that they're going to
promote scams or do anything like that
but it does mean that they simply are
going to provide the infrastructure
they're not going to go long or short
assets they're not going to trade these
assets in many cases they may not even
buy it it's unclear whether u.s bank has
any bitcoin on their balance sheet or if
any of the executives personally hold it
but it is clear that they now are going
to provide the custody services do we
like the fact that the banks are now
getting into this or do we think that
the industry should put a middle finger
up to the banks and say we don't want
you to financialize this asset the whole
point of this is to get rid of the banks
but i think there's there's an
interesting point there right is like i
think the traditional retail investor uh
doesn't care about this at all i think
to your point they may even not want
this right and say this isn't good we
should uh say fu screw the banks let's
not make them make any money on this
asset class but ultimately i think it's
a really good thing and i think it's
something they should care about because
these are institutional buyers right
these are the guys the big boys that
come in with hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars and can
really uh change and move the market and
see and you can see price appreciate
rapidly right so anything that banks or
whoever wants to do it right it doesn't
have to be banks but anything that we
can do to cater to these players and get
their money in the asset class and give
them exposure uh to a growing industry
it eventually helps all of us right from
a price appreciation standpoint so i
think it's important to separate the two
and say hey look we may not like the
actual players that are doing this and
accommodating this and the fact that
they're making money on it but
ultimately it's going to be a good thing
for the industry as a tailwind uh kind
of going forward so i think it's
something that we should appreciate and
something that we should ultimately say
hey this is a good thing uh and we
should be happy that they're doing this
john institutions have the ability to
move markets when they get involved they
literally they're bringing in hundreds
of millions of dollars into an asset
class with a fixed supply obviously it's
going to appreciate in value when they
do that and if it makes money they're
going they're going to figure out a way
how to get their hands on it and it's no
surprise that they're getting involved
and i'm gonna i'm gonna guess that we're
gonna see a lot more of them get
involved uh later on and kind of as this
uh matures even more past this 12-year
existence that's been in and then for
the ico part look i don't believe every
single coin that exists today is going
to exist in 15 20 30 years right so you
have to be careful about which asset
you're picking and not group them all
together uh we saw that with the icos in
2017 but i think there's going to be a
few asset winners in the coin space a
few exchange winners similar like
there's a few banks that win today
i think it's also uh important to to
separate like this is just a service
right for banks it's nothing to do with
kind of the decentralized nature of
bitcoin or the network or any of that
kind of stuff right this is a service to
cater to institutional investors that
want to invest in the asset class so as
a retail investor doesn't really change
anything except for the price might
appreciate right so that's something
that you should uh that you should be
excited about the entire time that
bitcoin had dropped from 64 000 to 30
000 one of the easiest hacks as to why
uh i would tell people you know uh that
would ask me like should they sell
should they not say look i don't get
financial advice but are you gonna sell
your bitcoin to the nation states
are you are you really gonna be the
idiot who sold your bitcoin to the
president of a country who should late
to the party are you going to be the
[ __ ] who sold your bitcoin to wall
street to a hedge fund to a bank well
guess what now here they're showing up
right and i can tell you what i'm also
not going to give them my bitcoin in
terms of putting it in their custody
products oh yeah i'm a huge believer
that there is some version of the world
uh some portion of the population that
needs access to these products and so
there's institutions there's family
offices foundations endowments maybe
even sovereign wealth funds uh public
companies etc they're going to need the
kind of financial services of incumbent
players centralized entities etc uh that
come from the wall street world that
already have decades of experience and
reputation and trust built around it
they have uh kind of regulatory licenses
they have private relationships etc
but the majority of people who are
already in they ain't going to use these
products right they don't they're not
waiting around for a bank to show up
with a custody product they've said to
themselves either i'm going to
self-custody it or i'm going to use one
of the crypto native uh firms and so i
think that what we're watching here is
just like we had the infrastructure get
built to get the crypto audience in or
the bitcoin audience in uh if you go all
the way back to 2011 2012 it was really
hard to buy bitcoin really hard to store
it right really hard to mine it et
cetera then we had a bunch of
infrastructure built that allowed for
individuals and uh uh kind of retail to
come into the market now what we're
watching is we're watching the
institutional infrastructure get built
that's going to bring in the
institutions there's kind of a cohort
adoption you get the individuals first
then you get institutions then you get
nation states in the institution you
both get public corporations or private
corporations and you get financial
institutions and what we're watching is
simultaneously that institution cohort
is exploding in adoption we've seen
obviously all the banks all the
financial asset managers etc now what
we're starting to see is who are the
bank customers right u.s bank doesn't
have a bunch of hedge funds as their
customers they have companies they have
foundations they have other types of
organizations those are the people
getting in the game now and it's
continued to provide this persistent uh
kind of demand as a tailwind for the
asset is going to obviously lead to uh
pretty rapid price appreciation fifth
largest retail bank in the u.s yeah so
it's just crazy to think about they're
starting to play remember coinbase has
more users than uh charles swapp
right so again anybody who's watching
this if you work at an incumbent firm
and you're not in the game get moving
because you're going to miss this entire
thing and what we're watching is every
single day in in the month of july
remember those numbers off the top of my
head 1.2 million new entities came onto
the bitcoin blockchain they didn't come
onto the blockchain via coinbase they
didn't come on through any sort of uh
traditional financial firm they didn't
come through uh any of your legacy
marketing channels etc they came
directly onto the blockchain you are not
only competing with your incumbent peers
you're not only competing with the
crypto native firms you're also
competing with the direct access to a
decentralized open monetary network and
so what we saw was twitter earlier this
year literally just turn on that open
monetary network and now they're 300
plus million users are able to access
and use that and they never had to open
another account that is the entire value
proposition of this asset we just
crossed 1.5 k likes which means we're
gonna give out another 250 of bitcoin
right now what i want you to do is i
want you to leave a comment in the chat
that explains what is the worst
experience you've ever had with a legacy
bank what's the absolute worst thing
that's ever happened to you with a
legacy bank do they shut down your
account do they stop you from pulling
your own money out do they wire your
money somewhere else by accident what's
the worst experience that you've ever
had with a bank we'll pick one person
we'll give them 250 so i i have a uh a
story that i can share go ahead this is
uh it's probably not i don't know if
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened i would have to think about it
for a second i guess but this happened
in the past week i went to go uh pay
rent right and the way i do it is i
typically would wire the money right but
uh bank of america is currently setting
up a new uh authentication system for
new accounts that you deposit money to
and it is taking 30 days they said the
entire month to set up and test the new
system so i tried to set up the account
online right so certain uh you know bank
transfers you can do online i go to set
it up and i was not able to do it no
explanation as to why it just literally
the button would not work like i would
click the button it just wouldn't go
anywhere there was no reason why all the
stars the the categories with the stars
i filled in correctly i thought i did
the right thing i've done this before
and literally the button was just grayed
out you couldn't click it no explanation
no nothing so i go to the bank and i'm
like hey what the hell uh three people
in line in front of me you know the the
lines are out the door at the bank it
takes hours two three hours to get in
front of someone uh i sit down in front
of someone and he's essentially like oh
yeah yeah we're testing a new system
like it's not gonna be working for the
next month like well one where was the
explanation of that two i had to come
into the bank uh for a relatively
smaller transfer right this wasn't some
massive uh wire transfer that i was
doing that you would assume you had to
go to the bank for wasted hours out of
my day no explanation just a terrible
process right and something like this uh
in the legacy bank network is is uh
common i would say right like these are
things that people deal with on a daily
basis wasting enormous amounts of time
uh money and all that kind of stuff so
it's it's frustrating obviously and i'm
sure people have similar stories that
they that they can tell too the banks
suck i mean let's just call what it is
the banks suck there are very few
experiences where people walk away
they're like wow that was amazing it's
pretty much every experience with legacy
bank is ah it got what i needed done it
could have been better but like it's the
best that we have there's very few times
i've ever gone to the bank and literally
just been blown away with customer
service or blown away with the
technological products or blown away
with how fast and efficient they are
right
i've told the story before they've shut
down accounts they've had me go in and
manually uh actually show them physical
documentation so they can approve wires
do all kinds of crazy stuff and so what
we're watching is this is a superior new
system it is a digital global system
that is decentralized it's open and
right now the user interfaces actually
aren't that good but the bar to beat in
the legacy system is so bad that it's a
better system uh even though those
interfaces aren't necessarily the best
yeah i mean i told you guys the story
the one a few weeks ago where i i went
in they had me uh literally they gave me
my signature from when i was 16 years
old that they had on file and said we
need you to copy this otherwise we can't
make the wire transfer my signature
changed i was 16 years old with mom at
the bank creating a bank account for the
first time probably putting some
lemonade sale money in there and they
wanted me to literally copy it otherwise
they wouldn't make the transfer so stuff
like that is just it's quite frankly
idiotic right and like you said there's
just never typically a good experience
there's there's obviously good people
that work at these banks and and they're
nice and all this kind of stuff but the
actual experience of going to a bank and
having to deal with kind of the legacy
system uh is terrible in a lot of ways
john what do you think
uh you got a grin on your face over
there like you better blast the bank i
have a million stories about how the
banks suck literally i have everything
from if you ever lose anything getting
getting identification to them wire
transfers everything in between i have
few experiences where
i really like working with the banks um
and it normally just is really that one
individual person at the bank it's the
customer service representative or the
bank teller or whoever it is the close
on the weekends thing always blew my
mind like that
like no one needs anything on the
weekends it's like the u.s stock market
the u.s stock market is closed more
hours a week than it is open and you
have to go to the bank what times the
banks close in the u.s four o'clock five
o'clock yeah what are y'all doing are
you not making any money at 6 p.m 7 p.m
8 p.m what's going on not only that but
like people work during the day so what
is going on i'm supposed to leave during
the day like people are supposed to
leave their job during the day to go in
there wait three hours to make a
transfer on something that they should
have been able to do online come on bro
they say you're supposed to pay to get
your money out yeah why don't you put
your money in here and then oh yeah by
the way it's gonna cost you 30 to make
the trend
one time i tried to move my money from
one account to another account at the
same bank and they tried to charge me
money i had a field day i was like
listen
i get it if we're sending it to another
bank you could lie to me and tell me you
got all these transaction fees whatever
yeah but from one account to another at
a bank no we ain't playing this game and
i remember the branch manager ended up
having to come uh talk to me and he was
like well you know this is just policy
whatever i said this sounds like you're
just being extractive with this right
all right i got a winner from the
giveaway i already picked it you already
paid you already picked it yeah but if
we get 300 likes we're gonna pick
another so who's the winner uh sebastian
i already uh put it in there john i'm
two steps ahead of you uh sebastian i
already left uh a comment for
sebastian's in the chat right now uh
well well he he tagged the guy
sebastian portella you just won 250
worth of bitcoin for free just for
watching the show we appreciate you
leave your twitter uh
account or your twitter handle at me
when you do it that's 750
if you like the video another 250
attribute we just go right now should we
just bam let's show we get another 250
right now yeah it's like the video three
hit the like button if we get to 2k
likes i'll give out another 250 dollars
worth of bitcoin it's getting ridiculous
one two three smash the like button when
we hit 2k likes we'll give out another
250 dollars is easy if you come here
we'll teach you things you smash the
like button more people on youtube find
it we'll build the biggest show in the
world and i can't wait i promise you
when we become the biggest show in the
world the episode earlier this week
already 250 giveaways are gonna be
nothing
earlier this week we had one of the ep
the episode has 62 000 views i'm calling
it right now squawk box has 125 000
people that watch it we're halfway there
we've been doing this for less than 90
days i promise you we're gonna build the
biggest business show in the world
that's our entire goal we just hit 2k
likes i'm giving out another 250 john's
got goosebumps
johnny
all right here's how we're gonna pick
who the winner is ready is i want you to
tell us in the chat right now what is
one topic that we have not covered on
the show that you want us to cover later
this week what topic around finance uh
business investing bitcoin crypto
whatever what's the one thing that you
want us to cover later in the show that
we haven't uh covered and we'll go ahead
we'll pick somebody and we will uh give
you 250 right here live on the show real
simple john's gonna monitor the chat
we're gonna keep going on topics and
then we'll go ahead and announce the
winner after we talk about this next one
all right we've got this graphic student
loans credit card debt on the rise of
crypto transactions now of course this
is not a real-time graphic because it's
kind of this like infographic i don't
know where john found this it says coin
payments i don't know what that is
there's a little alien down there at the
bottom kind of weird capitalist that
john found this uh but what this shows
us is a bunch of different uh data
points so first is that this is the
aggregated daily transaction count
across bitcoin ethereum and litecoin and
what you can see is if you go back to
2016 the daily transactions were under
250 000 across those three networks back
in 2016. by the time we got into mid
2017 we were now up to over 500 000
transactions and then if you look around
today we are now over 1.5 million
transactions across those three networks
bitcoin making up over 1.2 million so
the bitcoin transaction volume uh or no
i'm sorry the bitcoin transaction volume
went from 224 000 to 234 000 to about
230 000 on uh bitcoin today now a lot of
that is because on the layer one
technology what you got is you got tons
and tons of transaction volume but of
course what we had was we had slower
throughput and higher fees so now we're
starting to see a transition into the
transactions occurring on the second
layer on the layered two so the
lightning network has absolutely
exploded we know that the chivo wallet
in el salvador which uses the lightning
network has over three million downloads
and active users we know that twitter is
using the lightning network to onboard
their 300 plus million users it is by
far the most popular second uh layer in
the entire industry when we look here we
can see the average value per bitcoin
transaction in 2016 was only 2 400
today it is 32 000
a massive massive leap now of course
some of that is the bitcoin price has
just increased in us dollar terms and so
there's some natural appreciation of the
average value per bitcoin in dollar
terms but the average value per ethereum
same thing 500 to now 19 000 and then
litecoin 1300 to 5400 i have no clue why
uh some of those other coins are in
there but when we look at the bitcoin
one the 2400 transaction fee in 2016
that's a really big number if you were
to compare it to the u.s dollar system
the average transaction volume or the
average volume per transaction is much
much lower in the us dollar system when
you start getting into the average value
per bitcoin transaction being 30 plus
thousand dollars that's a big number
that is unheard of when it comes to
payment systems and so ultimately what
we are watching is not only the adoption
of a brand new digital decentralized
open monetary network but we are also
watching consumer behaviors change most
people would not be able to go under the
visa network and just send around 30 000
on average per transaction that's not
how the system works instead you have to
go to the bank you've got to send a wire
you've got to go through all these
different hoops pay all these extra fees
and so what we are seeing is the bitcoin
network is not only being used for the
micro transactions across the lightning
network where literally last night while
i was at dinner i sent joe one dollar
across twitter to show somebody and in
the comment i left you owe me a dollar
twenty-five but you can also i did do
that uh but i was wondering what that
was i was like but you can also go ahead
and you can send tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions or
billions of dollars of value in one
single transaction across this network
this is the beauty of these new systems
this is the new system that we are
ushering in where literally anyone in
the world with an internet connection
can plug into the system can send any
amount of value instantaneous and for
free and so when i see these average
value per bitcoin transaction explode
like that all that's telling me is that
one bitcoin's price is up a lot but also
two is the fact that people aren't
worried about or thinking about the us
dollar value of the transactions they're
actually probably denominating it in
bitcoin and so right now if you were to
send .5 bitcoin that would be you know
27 28 000
they just don't think that they're
sending 27 28 thousand dollars they
think about it as they're sending half a
bitcoin right yeah i don't think people
uh really appreciate or at least not yet
uh how big the lightning network's gonna
be right so twitter's obviously one
piece of that they just plug in and next
thing you know 330 million people uh
daily active users on the platform have
access to send tips via the lightning
network so obviously uh the ability to
do something like that is awesome
cross-border payments uh for essentially
they're essentially instantaneous and
they're almost free in most cases uh so
when you look at it in kind of the the
ability to scale this up rather quickly
you can you can see how that would
happen uh but i just think it's gonna be
massive right and this is that first
step and it's obviously going to take
time to get adoption and people to
understand it and companies like strike
to build on top of their current
processes and and products uh to get
more people on the network but yeah like
this is going to be huge
john what do you think
in august of 2020 someone did a one
billion dollar bitcoin transaction for
four dollars that was the fee four
dollars or four dollars defeat yeah um
someone earlier in september did two
billion dollars
transaction with a fee of 78 cents that
is unheard of in the legacy world it's
gonna change lives really it's awesome
of course the lighting network's the
best example of it where literally you
can pay uh essentially nothing to send
one penny or to send millions of dollars
and what i think most people don't
realize yet is not only are the fees
like everyone focus on fees it's really
easy it's really quantifiable right it's
like hey it's four dollar fee but also
the experience to send it right if i
right now send a wire to john uh and i
press send it
at 11 39 what will happen is it'll take
hours if not till tomorrow for that wire
to send depending on where which
geography johnson which geography i'm in
and on top of that the process to
actually send the wire is a nightmare
right i have to go i have to get john's
address i have to get his name to get
his account number i have to get his
routing number i have to go in there
i've got to put the amount i got to put
all this information there's memos to
fill out all this nonsense
with the bitcoin network john can
literally just hold up a qr code i could
scan it and bam we're done
like that is where this world is going
and people are starting to realize just
how valuable that can be we already had
the funeral for western union there's no
more there are no more
two three hour uh time transfers right
it takes multiple days it costs hundreds
of dollars in some cases depending on
the amount of money you're sending the
people on the other end of it don't get
it for uh 72 hours in some cases right
like this this is bad right when uh you
look at kind of the legacy institutions
and their ability to transfer money
across borders uh and for low fees it's
just non-existent right uh western union
we had the funeral they're done
lightning networks coming in
what are we gonna do for the winner did
we pick one uh for the hitting 2k likes
who do you got who you got
here's the winner for uh the last two
fans
padella how do you spell it f-a-n-f-a-n
fener padella you win
leave us your twitter
account and we'll get you the bitcoin
all right there's the winner for the
last one we're at 2.2 k likes right now
if we get to 2.5 k likes we'll give out
another 250.
every 500 likes today that we get on
this video we will give out 250 worth of
bitcoin
my suggestion to all of you is to get
your phones out get your computers get
your pigeons get your smoke signals call
your mom call your dad call your brother
your sister your neighbor your dog your
friend literally your ex-husband your
boyfriend your girlfriend sister's mom
go on instagram post it do whatever you
got to do but get as many people on this
video as you possibly can and tell them
to like the video because when we hit
2.5 k we're gonna give out 250 bucks a
bitcoin when we get to 3k we'll give out
another 250 of bitcoin you like how i
said to just go and get your brother's
sister's mom's girlfriend there's a
couple things done yeah so the smoke
signal was pretty good i laughed at that
i thought you were gonna add flares but
you didn't add flares and then you said
the the brother sister's mom's boyfriend
whatever that was hilarious
i appreciate you liking it but it's true
and my idea john props to john on this i
don't want to steal his idea but he said
my idea
and then i clarified before i delivered
i appreciate that john said yesterday
that if it was him john being the
intelligent man that he is said that he
would get some friends to get on the
show increase his chances of winning and
then they would split the pile of cash
that's a good idea jon
um for the winners i'm gonna make this
pretty clear we're pretty nice guys up
here i'm not chasing people down to give
you money so i need you to comment in
the chat at me so i see it your twitter
handle i'm i can't i can't change
people's
stuff going on we're giving away cash
trying to be nice guys here you're
giving me a headache come on
we're going to bring natalie on the show
here in a second but i do have to say
this one thing the reason why joe and i
are laughing so hard is yesterday john
had like a uh like i'm not a breakdown
but he looked at me he goes yo we ain't
giving out no more cash if these people
don't make my life easier because he
said that yesterday he messaged somebody
who is it the eight sleep winner
we still haven't had the eight sleep
winner uh uh claim it yeah all right
eight sleep winner whoever it was you
got till the end of today if you don't
claim the asleep we're giving it away
again tomorrow we're gonna pick someone
else yeah
john john was shook yesterday he was so
tired of it i would make it so easy for
someone to give me money it would be
ridiculous
i wouldn't make it a hassle at all so
trying to be a nice guy just at me in
the chat also yes you should go get a
good guy not a good guy all right we've
got natalie brunell here with us thank
you so much for doing this thanks so
much for having me i'm so excited all
right uh you just quit your job so
congratulations on that right
another person
another person quitting their job to go
full time to work on bitcoin which by
the way bitcoin just crossed fifty five
thousand dollars not saying it's because
the show's on but you know maybe it is
uh
tell us one why did you quit and then
we'll talk about what you're gonna do
next yeah so i've worked in legacy tv
news for over 10 years
and just in the same way that
decentralization is hitting finance i
think it's also hitting media i mean you
guys are making this show right um and i
just feel like i've been reporting for
the last 10 years on the front lines in
the trenches on some of the biggest
crises facing our country and when you
learn about bitcoin you start to connect
the dots that a lot of it has to do with
money and how broken our system is and
so i just got really passionate about
this space and i felt like there's a
huge gap in terms of financial literacy
in this country so i just i wanted to
help i want to educate people and i want
to spread the word talk to us about
going down the bitcoin rabbit hole
because i think we watched it like live
happen on twitter this started as like i
think you heard about bitcoin that i
think you read the bitcoin standard and
then it was just like you fell off a
cliff deep down in the rabbit hole and
then there was a podcast then all of a
sudden i saw you started interviewing
all these people i was like what is
going on who is this person but like
walk us through that journey of actually
discovering bitcoin and like how you got
kind of orange build yeah so i've
actually had bitcoin since 2017. i was
working at a station up in sacramento in
the state capital of california and um
heard about bitcoin because i was dating
a guy who knew someone at coinbase and
all the guys were talking about bitcoin
and crypto i was like what is this and i
really regret not learning more about it
then because obviously i would have a
lot more right now
but i bought a little um and then i
really started going down the rabbit
hole when the pandemic hit like markets
crashed i think everyone sort of
realized is this the fourth turning
things are never going back to the way
they were and i just started consuming
all the literature all the youtube
videos all the education online i could
read the bitcoin standard multiple times
read a bunch of books and i was like
hooked and i decided to turn my podcast
which i i had been interviewing people
about their lives and success stories it
was called career stories i decided to
just pivot focus solely on bitcoin
interview the legends including yourself
and learn more about why you guys have
this conviction and it turned into
something i didn't even expect i left my
job you've interviewed a whole bunch of
people michael saylor all the way on
down what are the biggest lessons that
you've learned from actually doing the
interviews like what are the takeaways
for you yeah and my claim to fame is
also having peter schiff admit that he
should have bought bitcoin which was
awesome
you know it's just been fascinating to
see how how different everybody's
backgrounds are you know everyone comes
from some people humble beginnings some
people have this you know massive
investment background
but ultimately everyone realized that
there's something wrong in our system in
our economic money printing society that
we live in and um bitcoin is the
solution it's the sort of life raft that
can fix a lot of the problems that are
facing this this country in the world um
so it's just interesting to see
everyone's like transformation down the
rabbit hole and how how much we all have
in common right we all come from
different backgrounds but ultimately we
want to help empower people we feel like
the system shouldn't be rigged against
us and and i think that this provides
financial freedom and access for
everybody i think that's amazing
now when you quit you didn't just quit
just to go do the podcast you're gonna
continue the podcast uh but also you are
gonna go create this training program
for women and this entire community
around uh women joining the bitcoin
community let's first talk about there's
not a lot of women right uh if i go on
twitter and i look at my twitter feed
not a lot of women uh when i go and i
say hey who should we bring on as guests
on the show there's just not a lot of
women to choose from and so uh it's very
obvious i think our youtube audience is
like 94
male uh and that's across the world
right so what is the issue or like how
do you identify why is it so male
dominant versus uh having more of a
balance of like 50 50 men and women yeah
i mean i don't really know the exact
reasons but if you just look at the the
world of finance in general and
investing it's predominantly male driven
um and i think that there were some
really interesting surveys that were put
out recently by block fi and other
companies saying women know about
cryptocurrency they even acknowledge
that the price is going to go up in the
next five years but they just feel
hesitant and they're not willing to
invest in it or they don't feel like
they understand it enough so i feel like
we need to change that right because
bitcoin is for everyone we need to get
all sorts of people involved and i think
that the gender gap really needs to to
decrease so that's you know something
that i really want to do i want to bring
more girls in i want to get the girl
memes going um and you know create like
a sorority and a community where women
can like network and and have their
voices uplifted in this space so you're
creating a training program for those
that don't know uh we've been we being
myself and a couple other folks have
been training as many people as we
possibly can in bitcoin and crypto uh
it's almost all men uh unfortunately and
what we've been doing is uh doing that
in the way that one we can get them
educated with two try to help them get
jobs uh we're gonna help you and you've
put together an entire curriculum it's
way better than ours
just because you actually have the skill
set to do it and talk to us about this
program in terms of like what women who
go through it are actually going to get
out of it yeah so this is not just
learning about bitcoin like fundamentals
of bitcoin and sort of how bitcoin
empowers um societies around the globe
but it's also the history of money it's
the history of our economic system
starting from the very beginning when we
had barter all the way to fiat
government money um when the federal
reserve was you know invented when we
went off the gold standard all of that
so we cover a huge amount of information
but it's very interactive um we have
five days a week of events discussion
groups social things um question and
answers and we have amazing coaches we
have an amazing guest panel of some of
the most successful women in the space
and again we just want to provide a
community for women where they can
engage with one another where they feel
like it's a safe welcoming space not
that you know twit bro twitter
is not welcoming but you know just a
place where women can see it as an entry
point to start to network and engage
with each other share ideas maybe
connect for future job opportunities and
just learn about bitcoin and our
monetary system and be able to also like
articulate the message to their own
communities
so when you think about uh women going
through this program well the part to me
that's so fascinating is like one you
can learn but two is the community right
and i just put in the chat i said you
know if you're a guy watching this go
tell your wife your girlfriend your
female friend a stranger at the store
like we need as many women in this
industry as possible how do you think
about the community aspect of that and
like why that's so important well i
think women in general we're so
community driven we love sort of the
idea of sharing things and being a part
of something bigger and so i think that
that's like the most important element
because you can go online by yourself
right you can watch a bunch of youtube
videos that's what i spent basically all
my free time over the last year doing i
read all the books but there's something
to be said about being able to engage
and interact live with other people who
might have the same questions as you or
maybe you learn from their questions
maybe you meet someone who becomes a
lifelong friend maybe they connect you
to someone in crypto that ends up
getting you a job but we're all just
like we're learning from each other and
i think connection's one of the best
things in this space which is growing so
quickly and i think there's a great
opportunity to bring more people in so i
got to interrupt you for a second we
just hit 2.5 k likes i'm gonna literally
go broke on this show uh-huh we're
giving away another 250
what i want you to do is uh i want you
to leave a comment in the chat
if your wife your girlfriend a female
friend etc owns bitcoin or not and what
they've talked about bitcoin right do
they get it do they not get it are they
scared of it what what's your experience
uh with it um and so leave a comment in
there and we will have john go ahead and
pick uh who the winners john's eyes just
rolled because he's like damn it i have
to do that
if you don't hit me up you're not
getting married i don't know what to say
i've added the guy a million times in
the chat i got a busy life going on man
this guy mike says his grandma's been
buying bitcoin since 2016. yes i mean
that's pretty good
having a grandma buying bitcoin it's
cool one thing that uh is also
interesting while we're waiting for
people to leave those comments there
make sure you keep liking the video and
uh and we'll go ahead and pick somebody
uh when we get done talking to natalie
but uh one thing also is your family's
not from america and i think that one of
the most interesting parts of this is
like many immigrants to the united
states uh have this almost like
cognitive dissonance right you live in a
western world country where there's
great infrastructure uh if i go to the
atm for the most part unless the banks
being stupid they give me my money uh
and sure we can complain all day about
the banks but like the currency is
somewhat stable and they're somewhat
good services that's not true around uh
a good portion of the world so talk a
little bit about your family kind of
coming here and like how that plays into
your interest in bitcoin yeah so my
family came here for the american dream
they didn't come here to necessarily be
you know rich like jeff bezos and have a
yacht and all that but they just wanted
you know a nice house the middle class
life a vacation for their kids good
schools um and you know for me i've
tweeted before that bitcoin is now my
american dream because i feel like over
the last
20 years since we've been in this
country things have just gotten harder
and harder my family lost everything in
the financial crisis they are
representative of the people out there
who you know have always held most of
their assets in like cash or savings
accounts they they don't know
necessarily how to invest and they they
see the stock market as something risky
they couldn't afford you know a big
house that's going to appreciate in
value so you know i see them as the
little guy and i all the people i've
reported on and interviewed over the
last 10 years i see the little guy and i
see the little guy constantly getting
screwed and i think that there needs to
be something done where you
give the power back to them to be able
to work for their money and then not
have it lose value let let it you know
go into your bank account and appreciate
like let you you know plan for the
future be able to save for the future so
that you can take care of your family
that's what's really important to me
because that's like that's my family in
a nutshell they they're good people
they've always followed the rules paid
their taxes like they should be able to
keep their money and not have it like
depreciate in value every year just by
having it in the bank john you got a
winner
yeah
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
rotate the roll here john's not gonna be
allowed to tom seems like he's getting a
little heated doing this so we'll have
to switch this up i don't know what to
tell you man
um
yeah i just lost the winner i had too so
um oh dave you got to pick another one
yeah
um okay cool uh mally sorrell which said
she's in finance and she thinks i'm
crazy for doing bitcoin
she wait uh who thinks that
mally's
says that she thinks that you're crazy
or that somebody thinks she's crazy
someone thinks she's crazy
all right so we're tagging
right now give us your twitter handle
and john a lot of people want to join
the course and they called you an
all-star by the way
just to hype you up
[Laughter]
um so talk to us about what is the goal
when somebody goes through the program
right like part of this is i'm excited
i'm biased right because uh cause we're
gonna work together but when you think
of a woman going through a program like
this i think there's people who say okay
they'll learn about bitcoin maybe
they'll go buy bitcoin there's going to
be a community they can talk about
things that maybe they're uncomfortable
talking about on twitter or whatever uh
but also there's this element of like uh
almost female empowerment around
finances totally and i always uh talked
to planet about this of like
uh i think it's
beyonce maybe i forget who says it but
somebody's like like if you want to
change the way the world looks like give
money to women and then like get the
[ __ ] out of their way basically yeah
right and if you do that like it
completely changes the way that assets
get allocated investments get made
people naturally like you invest in
people that have similar experiences to
you that look more like you and things
like that so talk through a little bit
of like what you see the impact being
yeah i mean i agree i've even heard
those stories of you know like giving
the micro loans to women in
underprivileged you know global
economies and they uplift their
community because they now can make
financial decisions and i just think
that there's something so special about
empowering women they have so much
purchasing power in our country i've
been reading all these stats you know
putting together the training materials
and it's like women make up the majority
of home purchases they make up the
majority of consumer spending they have
like 40 trillion dollars in um in
consumer spending behind them so you
know why aren't they investing more why
don't they feel comfortable with crypto
we have to give them an environment
where they feel empowered and feel like
they understand it they can communicate
with one another and the way girls
communicate with another with one
another and i just think it's super
exciting yeah i mean a lot of women want
to make smart decisions they just need
to be given that education and that
confidence and i think that this space
is going to be 50 50 before we know it
like i'm really excited about you want
to hear something wild that a lot of
people don't like to admit so i just uh
at uh galzara
on in the youtube chat just reminded me
of this uh mike green
wife made him buy bitcoin jason calcanis
wife made him buy bitcoin i actually
think jason can his wife bought the
bitcoin and he didn't and whenever
somebody was like hey you are uh you're
negative against bitcoin you're a bear
on bitcoin he's like no no my wife owns
some yeah like like that's always like
his defense
and so i do think that there's an entire
portion of the industry that just like
nobody really knows about like nobody
talks about it they're not on twitter or
whatever and so uh the the uh gauzera in
uh the youtube chat said my wife maybe
buy it too so like there is this element
i think that kind of uh gets played out
here that a lot of folks uh um uh don't
really talk about right yeah and we're
not risk averse i think women actually
take really big risks and in fact when i
heard about you know bitcoin from the
guy i was dating his friend was at
coinbase i ended up buying more bitcoin
than the guy i was dating i was like oh
i believe in this like i'm all in
so yeah i know i think i think there's a
lot of women that are excited about this
they just need you know the tools and
the information
so we have some breaking news right now
that we're going to all talk about
together i'm going to send this to matt
right now uh one of the uh evil empires
of the financial world has decided that
they are going to go ahead and start
participating in the bitcoin crypto
industry uh our friend uh george soros
oh uh george soros is fund now is
talking about participating so they
actually recently said they're gonna
sell stocks they're gonna buy bitcoin
cryptocurrencies but they've also just
said quote bitcoin has crossed the chasm
to mean to mainstream and so when we
start to see people like george soros
there we go got the tweet right there
from bitcoin magazine when we start to
see folks like um george soros and
others start to participate in this
industry it's fascinating to me because
these are the same folks that were
laughing at bitcoin in 2012 2014 2016
2018 but now they're finally
capitulating in and what it reminds me
of is it reminds me of the old saying
that you buy bitcoin at the price you
deserve like you just paid an ignorance
tax to buy bitcoin if you've waited
until 50 plus thousand dollars to buy it
i'm glad that you're buying it but there
is an ignorance tax for either not
paying attention not wanting to pay
attention or dismissing it future or in
the past right
yeah and i'm also one of those people
though that i think they're announcing
it now but they bought before i think i
think they bought probably bought the
dips and now they're finally ready to
come out there because it makes them
look good right i mean the price is high
now we're gonna admit that we went in
but yeah i know it's fascinating to see
some of the people do and about face and
say oh actually i'm gonna take this more
seriously i know you're familiar with
that with kevin o'leary right
i mean there's a lot of people that i
think regret either not you know
studying it enough or not buying more
when they had the chance but it's still
early like that's the thing it's still
early the people in my life who now ask
me hey bitcoin that's that's too
expensive i can't get in it's like
people don't realize you can buy a
fraction of a bitcoin it's not too late
you know this is an ecosystem we want to
grow because it'll empower everybody to
transact with people around the world so
i think that's a good point right like
everyone wishes they could have bought
it a hundred dollars a thousand dollars
two thousand dollars but ultimately at
fifty thousand dollars bitcoin could
still be really really really cheap in
the grand scheme of things right when
you look at fidelity was showing charts
to their clients where it could be 100
million dollars of bitcoin right like
it sounds absurd but in the grand scheme
of that yeah fifty thousand dollars
fifty five thousand dollars is really
cheap when it comes to that well they
said twenty thousand dollars was too
expensive yeah thirty thousand they've
obviously changed their mind a few times
now yeah well scaramucci said on my
podcast he was like you know just start
with one to five percent because i
sometimes ask my guests like for the
average person out there who has no idea
about bitcoin they're thinking about it
they don't know how much they should put
in i asked like how much should the
average family maybe they're super
affected by the pandemic maybe they lost
their jobs how much do they invest in
bitcoin and he was like
one to five percent like how how upset
are you gonna be if you lose one percent
right but the chances of that if you
look at the chart are very very low like
pretty much no one has lost money if
they bought bitcoin held it for at least
four years so that's this is actually a
pretty you know risk-free investment if
you are willing to hold it and one to
five percent can turn into you know 20
percent of your portfolio pretty quickly
as it keeps growing and uh and by the
way mooch thank you so much for
scholarships for the training course and
okay coin i really appreciate that too
we have a lot of young people that watch
this show and i think one of the biggest
things is upside right so if you put in
five percent you have a lot of earning
potential throughout your life you have
a lot of time right so if you're six
years old it's a little different what
allocation you can kind of put in but uh
for young people i think it's a
no-brainer to put well the other thing
too is that it's it's gonna be a massive
industry right like i think at this
point it's kind of a foregone conclusion
that digital assets in the digital space
is going to be a huge industry right
it's growing at a rapid pace when you
look at how many people are in the world
how many people are currently in the
industry and it's going to grow uh to a
certain extent so like
when you look at every asset within that
class bitcoin's actually probably the
safest asset right so when you think
about one three five percent uh in a new
asset class that you're scrolling you're
making a bet on it bitcoin is seen as
something that's kind of the safest end
of the risk curve you can go out further
along as as kind of the bull market runs
but ultimately
bitcoin is probably and has proven over
time to be one of the safer assets in
the whole space
we have another uh tweet here that uh
plan b i think is put it out and uh what
he basically said was uh
when these players come into the market
what's the retail investors aren't uh
are no longer the ones actually being
the only people in the market you get
these ideas of these cell walls and so
uh what he's specifically talking about
here is that cell walls are pure scare
tactics to scare you out of buying watch
them remove the cell wall and place it
higher as soon as the price approaches
the cell wall they really wanted to sell
large amounts they would do it in
stealth mode not signaling their
position and so the way to read this
chart right here is basically the green
is all of the buy orders in the order
book and then the red is all of the sell
orders in the order book and so when you
actually look at that big kind of cell
wall right that that kind of vertical
line up there of of red what they're
doing is they're saying hey somebody is
going to continue to buy bitcoin buy
bitcoin uh up until that cell wall well
if you see a big sell what do you think
that a bunch of you are gonna dump
bitcoin so if you think a bunch of
people are gonna dump bitcoin you may
sell your bitcoin because you think you
can buy it back at a lower price and
they're using the order books to
essentially signal and if people start
selling it then they just go and they
just move the cell wall and they end up
going and buying more and so these are
somewhat sophisticated um kind of
trading strategies or manipulations of
these order books again no one's
claiming anything is unethical or
illegal with it but this is not what you
get when it's just you know your grandma
buying five dollars a bitcoin every week
right this is getting into much more
sophisticated stuff and so i do think
that the market dynamics change as well
as more people come into the market that
necessarily haven't been there over the
last couple of years too right
yeah i agree and i'm not a trader so i'm
a holder i'm a hodler
john what do you think about things like
this with the cell walls
yeah
i kind of go back and forth on if at
some point in time you take a little bit
of profit you take the principle out of
your investment and you almost play with
house money at that point but then i
also think about fidelity saying it's
going to go to 100 million dollars a
coin and thinking if you ever took any
out you'd be an idiot if it got to that
point but obviously hindsight visions
2020 it's really tough to tell um but
like i said i'm very heavily out
allocated bitcoin because i'm younger i
have that potential upside for things so
my thinking is probably a little bit
different than the average person i i
think
the general way i think about this right
is like the majority of retail traders
that are involved in the crypto space
and bitcoin specifically are not
full-time traders right to your point
and and the idea behind that is like if
you're looking to allocate to a space
that you've done some amount of research
on and you think is going to grow and
specifically bitcoin or whatever asset
it ends up being you also have probably
most likely a full-time job of the other
side of this right that you're supposed
to be focused on doing a really good job
at so the easiest way to look at this
from an investment standpoint is just
put in your capital have a super long
time horizon only invest what you're not
willing to what you're willing to lose
and then just sit back and chill right
and when you look at it from the demand
perspective if everything keeps
happening what's been what's been going
on over the last three four five years
and is now accelerating actually you'll
make a lot of money doing it but the
whole idea that you're going to be
looking at cell walls and charts and
looking at things that you don't have
any experience in or background in or
knowledge of doesn't seem like a smart
idea right and it's more of just like
buying a really good asset holding it
for an extended period of time and only
risking what you're willing to lose i
want to talk about real quick john you
had a couple of friends in town over the
weekend i don't want to say who they are
but they're around your age
what's their thoughts on like bitcoin
and crypto and do they think that you're
crazy for having a larger allocation to
it or are they just like hey yeah that's
what everyone rh does they know i'm a
little bit crazy anyways
they understand it i've explained it a
little bit more in depth to them they've
taken a look at it they don't have
personally i don't think any allocation
to the asset class and i told them look
man if you put in one two three percent
it's not gonna move the needle for you
but we'll get you some exposure to the
asset they're really heavily on a lot of
like blue chip stocks i know they like
facebook apple kind of all the uh the
things that any financial advisor will
say hey allocate a big portion of your
stuff to this it's not going to draw
down 20 in a day um but i just went to
them look it's got a lot of upside and i
explained to them exactly what i told
you guys which was i'm younger i have
all those advantages of being able to
take that risk um and i see the upside
being being huge all right real quick
before we bring peter on here uh i want
to uh do something i can't remember if
we gave out 250 yet for crossing 2.5 or
not uh so we're going to go ahead and
give 250 again um mainly because that's
probably going to be the guy's money
that valley's been checked
last person definitely was not going to
miss this
but here's what we're going gonna do you
ready john you're gonna love this now
he's gonna love it too so
i want to give 250 dollars to someone's
mom to buy bitcoin yeah that's what i
want to do i want to give 250 dollars
bitcoin to someone's mom so the only way
i know how to do this is one if you're a
mom and you're watching go ahead and
comment
[Laughter]
her ears started ringing so give it away
that's one but two is uh if your mom if
your mom is in here we will give oh i
already got one all right here's the
here's who we are going to give we're
going to give 250
of bitcoin to the first mom i saw
comment which is kristin vc
you win 250 bucks of bitcoin first mom
on the best business show
to win bitcoin
there's there's people in this chat with
guy names that have been in this chat
for weeks and months now that are saying
i'm a mom
you start giving away money people start
doing crazy things
all right so we just picked the first ma
the first mom ever on the best business
show just got bitcoin 250 bucks here we
go
there are multiple men posting that they
are moms right now this is the problem
that we deal with uh natalie before we
let you go where can we send people to
learn more about the program and what's
kind of like the the 30-second pitch as
to why people should uh should join the
program yeah so head to btc4women.com
this is a chance to have live
educational in-depth workshops in
addition to discussion groups question
and answer is an amazing guest panel and
just building a community for women to
network and grow in their their
knowledge of bitcoin and just money
finance um so i'm super excited i hope i
hope you can sign up i hope your
girlfriend your wife everyone your mom
can sign up i think it's gonna be great
and thank you to your team for helping
me put this together i uh i hope that
all the moms all the girlfriends all the
wives uh earlier i put uh just find a
random woman at the store and tell them
like everyone should uh should go ahead
and do it all right we appreciate you
coming on uh what we're gonna do real
quick everyone is we're gonna go to
commercial i'm going to check peter's
audio and video he's calling in remotely
and then we will be right back and we
will talk to him about blockchain.com if
you can smash a like button we'll keep
giving out money we'll be right back
[Music]
the best business show is exactly that
it's the best why because it's the show
that me joe and john wish that we had
when we were learning
now we've got the best partner which is
so fun sofa is one of those platforms
that just hits different why sofi is
basically a super app it does everything
from allowing you to have budgeting and
saving tools to helping you refinance
student loans and they help you invest
in everything from etfs to individual
stocks pre-ipo companies and
cryptocurrencies use the link below or
go to
sofi.com to sign up for a sofi active
invest account and you can win up to a
thousand dollars
when you want anything to help you
create a better financial life sofi
likely can do it if you're looking for a
platform where you can go and do all in
one sofa is that place we're really
excited to partner with sofi on this
because we think they've built an
amazing product and we think that the
product and features that they have will
help simplify the lives of our audience
go check them out today at sofi.com pomp
and let us know what you think sofi.com
that's where we'll be
[Music]
we are back we've got peter here from
blockchain.com uh we're gonna bring him
up and i don't think people quite
understand how big blockchain is so
let's bring them up peter how are you
having me today i appreciate it
absolutely um let's just start first
with uh you were one of the earliest
people in bitcoin and blockchain
industry uh talk to us a little bit
about how you discovered bitcoin and
what really caught your attention to uh
to join the industry
yeah so i found out about it on the
mailing list um completely thought it
was like
crazy and not gonna work
i'd done a big project in graduate
school to look at like all the attempts
to create digital money all failures and
i was like okay here's another failure
you know a couple years later i check
back in on it there's all these people
around the world working on it i thought
a crazy number of people i think was
like a couple thousand people on bitcoin
dock at the time
and i decided to uh you know buy my
first coins which i did in a otc trade
which back then meant posting a message
on bitcoin talk and then sending a
random stranger paypal which is
coincidentally how you lose your paypal
account
um
but for me what was powerful about
bitcoin at the time
is still what's powerful about
cryptocurrency which is the idea of
building a borderless financial system
that really is meant for the internet
and for the internet economy and is sort
of beyond the reach of any one
government or person
so it's still regulated just like the
internet's still regulated on some level
but it's really cross-national and
brings the whole world together into one
financial market
and one financial system on a level
playing field and that felt like one of
the biggest ideas
that we would be part of in my lifetime
and i wanted to be part of that and
started building crypto products and
you know that was many years ago and
still building crypto products every day
so one of the aspects of this is people
have no clue how big this thing is right
you started i think blockchain.com uh in
2011 if i uh understand correctly and
the numbers that i've seen publicly are
that about one-third of transactions
that occur in bitcoin take place on
blockchain.com uh you've created about
76 million crypto wallets and you've got
about 35 million verified users in more
than 200 countries uh one how accurate
are those numbers and then two where is
all of that growth coming from like why
are people coming to you all uh to go
ahead and join
yeah so the numbers are completely
accurate you can verify some of those on
the bitcoin blockchain and they would be
insanely expensive to fake um and so
they're they're definitely real
i think the most interesting thing about
that transaction count is that when we
raised our series a seven years ago we
were about 14 of all transactions so
it's roughly doubled in that time period
and i actually expected it to go down in
that time period at the time i predicted
it would go down the other really
interesting headline stat about the
business is that the consumer products
are not you know institutional volume or
exchange volume but just the consumer
product has now transacted over a
trillion in volume
um which is crazy when you think about
it like a trillion in volume for a
consumer
you know payment product consumer
financial product is
you know astronomical
um
why do people choose us i think it's
about trust it's about the brand and the
name you know we have an incredible
funnel for people wanting to show up to
the space people show up you know and
they find our site um but we're also
trusted and
you know when you have as many users as
we do people usually recommend a wallet
to their friends they you know it's
crypto is a very social phenomena
and you know it's like a law of large
numbers like
if you started out with blockchain
you're probably going to recommend
someone else to blockchain and so on and
so forth
um
the other interesting thing about our
business is mostly outside the u.s so
about 80 of our business is outside the
united states so we're really large in
europe um latin america eastern europe a
few other key geographies
growing super rapidly in africa right
now
um but we're very different from like a
coin base for example which is is very
us dominant uh we're really there for
the rest of the world
um it's been a phenomenal ride when you
think of the institutional side of the
business versus the retail side of the
business uh it's very obvious that
you're getting tons and tons of activity
and user acquisition how much of its
institutional versus retail and then
like what's driving those two different
cohorts
so our business is about 50 retail today
by revenue and about 50 percent
institutional my revenue
what's driving the institutions is two
things one there's been the rise of
crypto institutions what i mean by a
crypto institution is a firm that is
native to crypto so not a client uh but
polychain would be a crypto native
institution
right
there's also driving the market is
institutions from tradify coming into
crypto so our last financing was led by
bailey gifford which is one of the
world's largest asset managers you have
the bayley giffords of the world coming
into crypto now and so the two things
are driving one the national capital
velocity cycle in crypto which is
creating these multi-billion dollar
crypto institutions and on the other
side
um you know huge asset managers that are
coming into the institutional side of
crypto
on the consumer side of crypto
a lot of it is driven by retail
investing and then retail financial
services and it just really depends on
which country you're talking about so in
africa they're using crypto to invest
but they're also using it very
transactionally same is true for latin
america
you know in the us where we're seeing a
lot of really strong growth right now
it's really about investing it's not
about transacting
and you're hoping to see that shift over
time
talk to me about building the
organization itself obviously you guys
have seen immense growth from a user
perspective uh you recently moved your
headquarters to miami as my
understanding which is awesome
appreciate that uh but where are you
finding talent how do people actually
get a job at blockchain.com and what are
the types of roles that you're seeing
people kind of transition from the
legacy world into this new world
so our u.s headquarters is in miami now
and we're really excited about that um
i'm also moving to miami i
should have a beer sometime but
weather's great but uh you know
our global headquarters is still in
london
uh which is where i'm sitting today
and
the team is expanding really rapidly so
on one hand it's a really small team
we're only about 250 people we've always
had the idea that you know you want to
hire really high impact hires and as few
of them as possible rather than trying
to build a really huge team
uh but that said you know in the last
year we've hired 100 people we'll
probably hire 100 people over the next
year what we're looking for in people
is you know talent whatever their domain
is you know we're about half engineers
but at the same time we want to look for
people with an intellectual curiosity to
learn new things because crypto's always
changing
and then on top of that we want people
who are really passionate about crypto
you know in the early years of hiring
team members sometimes we hire someone
who's just like a brilliant engineer or
a brilliant devops person
that's great but if they don't really
believe in crypto and the mission of
crypto
it's really hard for them to be
effective over time because it's hard to
work in crypto there's a lot of
volatility there's a lot of traffic
surge it's a very high security high
stakes environment
and if you don't believe in the
underlying market
it's really hard to make it work long
term in the industry
talk to us about regulation obviously
we've seen an immense conversation there
everyone from jerome powell to janet
yellen gary ginsler etc all being asked
are they going to ban it what do they
think how do we think that the rules
should evolve we see politicians
constantly battling back and forth we
should put more regulation in place we
should put less regulation in place then
we have the market participants also
with their opinions like how do you see
the regulatory environment today and
how's that going to evolve over time
look it's complex and i think it depends
on what part of the world you're talking
about so
you know in the eu the process has been
very administrative pretty predictable
you know our primary regulator is the
financial conduct authority in the uk
engaging with them is very different
from engaging with u.s regulators
i'm much more optimistic about you know
the regulatory regime in europe in the
uk
you know in singapore
the us has become a political issue
so it's now become an issue where you
have political parties staking out
territory
and it's become a voting issue like
increasingly people are going to vote
for politicians based on their stance in
crypto and when an issue becomes a
political issue it's hard to predict
uh and so
i think it's going to be
a very volatile couple of years in terms
of crypto regulation in the united
states
um
i think it's kind of on the industry to
do a better job of educating lawmakers
but more importantly educating voters
about why crypto and why innovation
matters to the united states
because ultimately that's who we have to
go to like the us is a democracy
it is ruled by the voters at the end of
the day
and we need to make our case to the
american people about why our industry
matters why it counts
and you know why it's more important
than just the headlines they read about
you know shiba or doge or whatever else
when you start to think about the
various products you've already built
are there things where you're like hey
this is a market opportunity we've
definitely got to go build something
there uh or some sort of a feature or
service that you really guys are focused
on over the next you know 12 to 18
months
yeah so the fun thing about blockchain
is that
at this point we're kind of like a
crypto holding company and we build all
this stuff all the time right so like
you know people are like why are you
still working i'm like well because i'm
having the time of my life i have this
incredible platform where we have talent
we have liquidity we have capital
and we have infrastructure and we can
just go out and build like all kinds of
new [ __ ] all the time right so a lot of
our biggest businesses today are
businesses that we've built in the last
three years
um
and we've built so many things of
blockchain over the years that have not
worked out and we could talk about all
those failures too
but
what we're seeing in the market today is
the need to make it easier to use
multiple chains at the same time
like
you know if i own bitcoin but i have
bitcoin sitting on four different chains
or layer twos or whatever
like how do i manage that how do i get
the bitcoins to the right place how do i
do that in a seamless way like how do i
support multiple chains in a way that
isn't completely
you know mind-numbing to the user
um
and that is a big product problem that's
kind of on the consumer side right
on the institutional side i think it
really comes down to stability
infrastructure and tooling
and really building that out in a robust
way that institutions can be happy with
um and i think that
you know even though we started building
that business three years ago
we've probably got
years to go
before we're
in the place that
we really want to be in terms of being
the best partner to institutions
i've got two of my brothers here with me
what questions you guys have for peter
hi peter thanks for doing this uh i i
guess my question would be around like
you've obviously built an extremely
impressive business you know in europe
in the u.s and et cetera uh but like
what keeps you up at night right like
what are you worried about uh long term
i worry about regulation a lot
yeah i think for us like we're big right
we throw off an insane amount of revenue
every year
profits you know we can hire lobbyists
lawyers
fund you know political
facts whatever we have to do right
if they come up with a license we can
apply for it and we can comply with it
if they tell us to kyc every crypto user
we have the infrastructure to do it
we wouldn't have been able to do all
that
when we first started this business
seven eight years ago right
and i worry a lot about building the
future and building a huge market in the
ecosystem because today we're tiny right
like we've achieved a lot in the last
eight years but the whole ecosystem is
tiny today
how are we going to do that if you can't
start a business and you can't innovate
right and you look
coymace
blockchain.com
the other big players we should be
regulated to some extent
and we are regulated you know we have
a blockchain.com we have like 60
regulators that we're dealing with
but if you're a little startup like you
should be able to build you should be
able to innovate you should be able to
do that without needing like a 30
million a year legal and compliance
budget
um and so i worry about that a lot
because without those new companies
about those new protocols without those
new tokens and projects and experiments
what is our industry you know how do we
grow it over the next five to ten years
yeah and i guess on the back of that
like
over the last five or ten years since
you started blockchain.com how has your
investment in legal compliance lobbyist
in washington like how has that trended
over time and how has that grown
it's grown a lot
[Music]
i'm not sure i even want to run the
number about the growth rate of that
budget
it's certainly not gone cheaper at any
point
uh
i think the second thing i worry about a
lot though is risk management
there's a lot of companies in our space
that have gotten a pretty big size
without going through a downside yet
like without going through a down cycle
which means that their risk management
is uh largely untested
and
because we're so active in the market as
an investor
you know as a credit provider as a
liquidity provider
we see a lot and i can tell you that
risk management and risk systems
are not where they should be for some of
the firms in our space
and that keeps me up at night because
there's no one to bail anyone out on
crypto right that's the beautiful thing
about it
but the you know natural market
economics of blow ups
are not fun
for the other people in the market
and i do worry about risk controls a lot
of firms in space
gotcha john what questions you got yeah
peter thank you for doing this very nice
to meet you so i am curious you are the
co-founder and ceo of blockchain.com can
you talk about how the hell you build a
company like this and then where you
guys are going from here
uh well i did it with a lot of people a
lot of help um
it's not you know building a company
like this is not a solo sport it's a big
team sport
and i've had to grow a lot as a person
um when i was very young when i started
this journey and i'm still super young
i'm only 32.
it required a lot of personal growth a
lot of
rethinking the way i did things a lot of
me i mean like
i had to admit that i didn't know how to
do things a lot right to get better at
them
um but i think the number one thing that
i tell entrepreneurs like when i invest
in them and they're like asking for
whatever advice
is
you know
just make steady progress
like
inch forward
day by day
preserve as much optionality as you can
find the things that you love doing in
the business that make it fun for you so
you don't lose the joy and the passion
and then
hire really great people that you love
working with
like you should want to love working
with your team because it's your team
if you're the ceo and founder of a
business and you don't love the team
you're working with the only person you
can blame is yourself
because you have the power to change
that right so
love the team you're working with
um
and if you can do that and you can just
keep going forward and don't get
discouraged and don't pivot you can get
somewhere and you know get lucky
definitely peter talk to us about uh the
market itself we're sitting around you
know 54 000 or so bitcoin price 55 000
how do you see the rest of this year
playing out in terms of of bitcoin
i honestly think we're gonna see your
hat happen
like
that's it only 100k
only 100 get
no i think that q4 is gonna be strong
like we're settled in for a crazy q4
um
you know i'm really excited about what's
going on in ethereum
i think that if you asked me two years
ago if i thought eth was going to win
out as kind of the dominant smart
contract platform or if one of the youth
2.0s would happen i would have told you
i didn't really know
i think that we've seen scaling is going
to happen
because of that you know i'm really
bullish on youth right now and super
excited about all the innovation that's
happening there on layer 2 and on youth
2.0
and that's really cool because you're
going to be able to build apps like
there's going to be crypto app stores
like we will be able to put an app store
in our wallet where any developer could
launch
a financial services app built on top
defy into our app store
like how cool will that be
and i think we're like a year away from
that being a reality
how do you think about personal
allocation or like portfolio
construction right you're in the space
obviously you've got like outsized
exposure to the equity of a
infrastructure type business do you
think about uh uh bitcoin and eth as
like the main components do you think
about the long tail like just walk
through like the framework you use in
terms of uh allocating to the space
uh yeah someone asked me once like how
much of my net worth i had in crypto and
i said it was like at least over 100
[Laughter]
um
yeah you know i'm like the crazy person
that like
sold all my equities right before cobin
and bought more ethereum
so
not my private stock my like public
equities portfolio so maybe i'm not the
right person to talk to about like for
safe and responsible portfolio no we
want what's the crazy portfolio
allocation yeah by the way you are
talking to three guys that are basically
the same thing so uh you have uh you
have uh company here
yeah so
in the crypto space i think about
constructing my portfolio in a way that
minimizes
regret
so
you know i have a solid position in
bitcoin
i have a solid position and whatever i
think is going to be the market leader
and market standard three four years
from now which for a long time was
bitcoin and for me now personally is
ethereum
and then i have you know about 25
percent of my portfolio in
what you could call venture crypto
investments whether those are companies
or those are you know new protocols or
venture funds
you know i'm a gp and an lp and
our venture fund here at blockchain.com
which is done really well
i'm a lp and a couple other early stage
crypto funds um and then i've done you
know some investing in early stage
protocols outside of that as well and i
think about that being like 25 percent
of my portfolio with 75 of my
crypto portfolio away from
blockchain.com
being you know large cap coins
got it and then when you start to think
about uh allocating capital internally
so blockchain.com huge business uh and
somebody comes to you with an idea how
do you think about like almost trying to
like disrupt yourself or uh allocate to
r and d are there certain decisions or
trade-offs or frameworks that you're
using there
yes and we you know we run a
you know a number that is measured in
billions and so it's a lot
um
i spent a lot of time studying cios
and studying how jeff bezos allocated
capital because in some ways amazon is
like a holding company for the internet
infrastructure capital people and they
just kept building adjacent businesses
right
and i think what i learned from that
study was one
you need to have a framework that makes
it quantitative and not qualitative
it needs to be about the opportunity
so it needs to be about
the opportunity
in the market size in front of you
and
so when we are looking at an opportunity
internally to like build a new business
or do r d
we're going to look at
how big is the opportunity
how much capital does it take us to get
to the first step
the first step being like where we can
get customer feedback
so time people capital financial capital
to get to the first market test where we
know if this is going to work or not
and then once it's working we can put
capital you know once customers have it
they're using it there's some product
feedback then we can attack it with
capital and people because we can size
it correctly but it's really about like
sizing these bets
um
and then you know inside of our business
we're actually you know putting
principal capital work you know lending
um
you know our whole prime brokerage
liquidity provision
venture investments i'm really looking
at return on capital and return on
equity
and so what's driving those decisions is
both immediate return on capital and
return on equity and then what i think
the best way to allocate capital is to
achieve long-term return on capital and
return on equity
how do you think about cutting an
investment so let's say you allocate
capital somewhere you've got you know
this grand vision of what's going to
happen do you evaluate at any point like
all right if we don't hit these metrics
by certain date or if we hit these
obstacles we're going to go ahead and
pull the plug on this project or this
like r d effort
it's one of the things we're best at
actually
is what i call killing the bad trade
and it's a advice that i give people all
the time when you make an investment or
you know a trade and you had a thesis
and it's not working
if you can't explain why it's not
working and what's going to change
no matter what it costs you you need to
cut it you need to end it and you need
to separate yourself from the emotional
pain of that
one way of doing that is like
celebrating mistakes so like a
blockchain we celebrate mistakes each
year we have like mistake day where
everyone
well i share my biggest mistake of the
year and invite other people to share
their biggest mistake of the year and
share what they learn
and we celebrate those mistakes and we
celebrate those learnings because
the only way to be aggressive and try
out new ideas and iterate and you know
take a moon shot is to know when to like
shut the rocket down
um and you have to be super disciplined
and cold and almost unemotional about it
when you start to understand this kind
of capital allocation strategy
do you do it also not only with the
products internally
but also when you're evaluating like
these early stage protocols or early
stage investments that you're making
whether it's off the balance sheet
personally whatever um
is there some sort of way that you
evaluate like follow-on investment
decisions uh by the same criteria
absolutely it's like
tell me you know i'm always asking you
like tell me your roadmap
tell me how you're gonna execute against
it
how do we know if we're on track or
we're not on track
you know so if you tell me hey peter
like we're gonna build a protocol for
you know uh tipping on
twitch
and you launch a protocol for tipping on
twitch and it doesn't go anywhere
then like
we either need to understand why it
didn't go anywhere and how we're going
to fix it and be very confident in that
which is like underwriting a new
investment
or we need to like write it off or sell
it
right
but like you have to be in like a
quantitative like evidence-based
framework
yeah john it's really interesting when
you start to think about uh kind of the
allocation of capital across this and
then also at the same time building a
business right like you're building a
business plus you're also thinking from
an investment standpoint a lot of the
same activity yeah it is
uh
it makes you kind of like double down on
on the investment in the industry in
general but it's growing at such a fast
pace um it's
it's exactly what you kind of want to be
doing yeah is the business encrypted how
you allocate your capital really matters
to the long-term success of the business
absolutely and also what you do with uh
your balance sheet if you hold it in
crypto currencies if you hold it in fiat
um and there's so many different ways
that people utilize it we were talking
to
the guy the other day about how he took
a single percentage of his fiat balance
sheet that was hundreds of millions of
dollars and actually put it into bitcoin
or into stable coins
peter like what has been your guy's
strategy and how has that evolved over
time when it comes to your balance sheet
if it has changed i guess
yeah because our value because our like
movements are large we don't usually
like talk about specifically what we do
but one kind of cool thing that i can
tell you is that we keep all of our
retained earnings in crypto or crypto
investments
so
you know every dollar that we make from
the crypto industry
in the crypto ecosystem providing
services to clients
we're going to put back into the crypto
industry
when you think about uh whatever the
allocation is for the strategy do you
have periodic reviews of it or do you
simply say hey like this is what we're
going to do for like the year or like
how do you think about it every every
week sometimes more than once a week
so you so it's uh and the reason why i'm
asking is uh in some crazy way like i
think there was a fidelity study done a
while ago the best investors were the
people who forgot their password or uh
died right it was just like they just
didn't touch it and just over a long
period of time it compounded uh there's
other people who are really good at kind
of tactically moving around allocations
and stuff like that and so with the
balance sheet uh whether it's your
personal balance sheet or with a
company's balance sheet uh you can take
you know kind of a couple of different
strategies so you guys really are
evaluating on a on a pretty uh periodic
basis is that because
the market changes so rapidly or is
there some other reason why you're doing
it so so often
well a couple things when we're
investing the venture side we're
long-term holders we're going to sit on
that for you know
in some cases many years now
but we also run a business that has
working capital to prime brokerage right
like a merchant bank for crypto and we
need to efficiently allocate capital
between business lines
so the lending deaths may need a lot
more capital
this week next week maybe it doesn't
right it's not it doesn't you know
change dramatically week over week but
we still need to like step back look at
our business each week and say okay
where are the returns on capital what
does each business unit need and how do
we allocate the capital between them
efficiently
yeah
it's fascinating when you start to to
kind of put frameworks around this and
understand hey here's how we're going to
allocate here's how we're going to
evaluate whether it's working or not
we're willing to cut things and then
reallocate so uh pretty cool what what's
your pitch uh before we let you go
what's your pitch in terms of uh uh
folks who are looking at blockchain.com
all the various products and services
why should they come and use that stuff
with you guys
at the end of the day i think the best
reason to use us is that we really
really care about our customers
we're like here to build whatever you
need
to be part of the crypto
financial system
and to
do what you want in the crypto financial
system so more than probably any other
business in the space we're willing to
build bespoke solutions we're willing to
start with you when you're really small
and grow with you when you're really big
like we've had customers start with a
thousand dollars of bitcoin and you know
become ultra high net worth
institutional customers over the last
five six years
like we're here for you
we at the end of the day are a really
customer client driven business
um you know the extent that i'm still
talking to customers every day
it uh it is absolutely fascinating to
see just how much you care and uh and
kind of how involved you still are which
is a kudos to you where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find uh blockchain.com
products
well you can go to blockchain.com it's a
a little known url um
but uh you know look i'm on the internet
i'm one more peter all words
on twitter so you can find me there um
try to not find any of the scammers that
are pretending to be me all the time
uh and then you know look if you ever
have an issue or an idea that i can be
helpful with you can send me an email
it's just peter blockchain.com
now the uh last question i'm going to
ask you is what if you had to guess
right now do you think blockchain.com
the actual url if you posted it for sale
today what do you think it would go for
uh i don't know 20 30 million
oh i think that's low
maybe more i mean
there's somebody out there who created a
fake coin that's got a bunch of coins
they trade you and then be 50 100
million i think
voice.com voice.com went for 30 mil i
could probably sell blockchain.com to
like one of the new
layer two like one of the new eth 2.0
guys for like a couple hundred million
right
easy
easy like if you got 10 billion dollars
of monopoly money
what's 100 ml between friends
and then it's like but then you know
what do you do with like
300 million of you know random youth 2.0
coin you sell as much of it as you can
as fast as possible and hope you get 50
million now
[Laughter]
right isn't that what they do i don't
know
awesome man listen thank you so much for
coming on i'm excited you're moving to
miami we'll definitely have to hang out
when uh when you get here anyone who
wants to learn more about blockchain go
to blockchain.com follow peter on
twitter and uh and we appreciate you
doing this man
thanks gentlemen
we'll talk soon buddy
awesome all the time man you like him
huh yeah he's building a massive
business yeah it's very big i don't know
what the last valuation is but it's
multiplied by five six billion yeah
somewhere
in the business very smart guy yeah
he's talking about rug poll
you like that term
yeah all right said 100k that was a
little disappointing like we're gonna go
north of that i think this is going
higher all right we'll be conservative
to the public ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls we are at over 3k likes which
means we're going to give out the last
250
right here live on the spot and then
we're going to get out of here 12 40 i
got things to do i got places to be
people giving me [ __ ] yesterday because
i said two hours of work hard day it's
all right no lewis was giving you [ __ ]
yeah sorry we're gonna have lewis come
on the show one no we're not
no i'm not subjecting anybody to that
that's fine and right now he's so upset
that we're talking about him and he
can't respond yeah right matt and jordy
yeah that's a turtle here yeah hey louis
can you hear me now
that's a good one that was a very good
one inside joke inside joke all right
here we go on the count of three
everyone press the like button one two
three press the like button we're gonna
pick one person for 250 bucks uh to give
out
by the way lewis just responded to us
said i would bring the [ __ ] heat
[Laughter]
uh all right we're gonna give out 250
bucks this is how we're gonna pick it
ready in the comments
what i want you to leave is tell us the
one guest you want us to bring on you
leave a name of a guest in there we're
gonna pick one person
and we will go and we will get them it's
that simple who is the one person you
want us to bring on the show uh and
we'll just go get them we'll tell them
hey look the audience wants you to come
on here uh who is that person
jacqueline wilnick sailor jerome powell
jordan peterson elon musk jamie dimon uh
robert kiyosaki kevin o'leary
a bunch of scammers
robert kiyosaki's on there as well tony
robbins gary vee janet yellen donald
trump gary gensler
naive buchelli breedlove
jre
these are all good names
but you know what
i know who i'm going to pick right here
here we go
david annens you win and the reason why
you win david is because you said that
we should bring andrew schultz on
and you know what andrew schultz i don't
hear andrew schultz
chirping as much anymore we tried to we
tried to get me to go on the show again
but we couldn't make the dates lined up
but andrew
bitcoin is going to be at an all new
all-time high soon you should come on
our show yeah you're going to be calling
your pizza boy for long yeah he's got
fiat shoes he said something dumb about
me too we should get him on here
he said something dumb about you yeah he
said i was the etherium of the poplar
family
[Laughter]
but i will say you know what i think is
hilarious about andrew schultz right now
i hope he sees this clip he's been
chirping on the internet saying that
he's the uh he's the greatest
reporter he's the greatest mma reporter
of all time or the greatest mma reporter
in the world and ariel helwani freaking
out over it he's like nah no you're not
and schultz is he is
so i tend to think that andrew schultz
is the greatest mma reporter in the
world uh so you know there you go that's
positive but we'll get we'll get shultz
on here at some point uh did he sell
i mean i don't want to ask him that that
would be real disappointing if he did it
all his friend's going to get rich what
he's doing is that what he said all his
friends were putting money
i know akash didn't sell no way no way
no
way but he was holding all kinds of
nonsense too it's all right we'll bring
them on they they ran away they ran away
from miami that's why they were buying
uh stuff other than bitcoin
no comment
they were in miami they liked miami then
miami uh somehow kicked him out i think
they just got you know eaten up chewed
up spit out it's fine that's fine uh but
the infamous tour in all seriousness uh
andrew schultz is on his infamous tour
right now from everything that i've
heard people have gone have said it's
amazing you should absolutely go and
check it out um you know contrary to
what you would see on the internet he's
actually a good guy he's somewhat funny
sometimes um and i think you guys would
all like it i'm sure he's a great person
i just said i like him she didn't sell
his buddy only because he went on joe
rogan's show was like yeah pom-pom got
me i lost all my money
yeah you're like dude what the hell just
hold on for a little bit
like no he's actually a good guy he's a
good guy
yeah but that doesn't erase that he lost
all my money
he's a good guy but he lost all my money
no just hold on
no it's all good all right uh that's it
for today's show i appreciate it a lot
of people want mr beast to come on oh mr
b we'd get jimmy on here yeah we could
do that um
real quick david and then make sure that
uh
uh you post your twitter handle so that
jon can uh can message david
so you know that you know that thing is
going on with the uh uh brian laundry
the guy that his girl girlfriend died
and he was on he's on the run now tim
dillon says he did it there's
there's a headline right now in the new
york post that his neighbors are
charging the media thirty five hundred
dollars to stake out
there's a way to make it the media wants
to go and sit outside the house and
record and do all the stuff the the
neighbors are charging 3 500
an hour
a day i don't know probably can you
imagine walking up to cnn bank list
you're all gonna have to go down the
street but if you pay me 3 500 an hour
you could change it up when you want
lemonade you want some donuts what do
you need a blanket at night no problem
just pay me 3 500 bucks an hour price
for everything yeah tim dillon just for
the record tim dillon did tweet he said
i'll save everyone a bunch of time he
did it
yeah
all right appreciate you guys hope that
uh this was a great one we appreciate
everyone tuning in and uh we'll see you
guys tomorrow thanks so much for
watching subscribe make sure you go to
silicon.com
make sure you like the videos see ya
[Music]
you